I hate intros Chihaya Fudo season one
really kicked things out for the
introduction of Chihaya aya say who's
trying to start it got it to club at her
school that she'd just transferred to
she soon finds out that one of her
childhood friends named Tai Chi Mishima
is attending the school also we get a
flashback of when they were kids and she
haya meets the new transfer student to
their school oughta tell what aya who's
bullied by the other kids for being for
too high a defense him and they end up
becoming friends
she asked him what his dream is which is
when he introduces her to Kat attack he
stomps her in their first match but
that's where she developed her love for
the game episode two died she's kind of
a douchebag back then so him and the
other kids continued bullying out of
town while Chihaya does her best to
defend him
when Taichi says that data has nothing
good going for him she brings up Khadija
they conveniently have a school gotta
take competition coming up when Taichi
calls out of town saying that he's gonna
win the competition odd attempt for the
first time stands up for himself each
scene during the competition Taichi sees
how strong oddity is so he steals his
glasses to give him an edge when they
face up out of ten is still doing well
because he memorized where all of the
cards are but when Taichi starts moving
them around he begins losing ground
Jiraiya comes to his rescue saying that
she'll play in his stead since he
doesn't have his glasses it's a close
match that comes down to the last card
and the last card just so happens to be
the card that auditor labeled as
chihaya's card because it starts with
Chihaya Fudo as soon as she hears the
start she immediately goes for the card
winning the match later Taichi returned
out it says glasses and a minute to
stealing them while requesting that
attitude not tell Chihaya because he
doesn't want her to hate him yiii
episode 3 the three of them start to
hang out more and join the [ __ ] outta me
kata to society to get more practice
well there they meet the instructor
Hideo hah tada who will play a part
later on but they also meet another kid
named hito
things get a little tense with Hiro and
this ends up turning into a 3v3
competition against him and his friends
the match is another stop because audit
SOP and after the match we find out that
audit two won the national competition
five years in a row for his age group
the three of them had fun playing
together so they decide to enter a 3v3
competition being held and start
training for
however things change when Taichi gets
into a new prestigious school and a data
is moving away also meaning they won't
be able to play together much longer
episode 4 to come back to the present
where we learned that kata two players
are divided into classes based on skill
Chihaya is B class and playing her
promotions to earn a class she tells
Taichi that if she gets a class then he
has to start a kata to club with her she
ends up winning her promotional and is
super excited to call auditive who she
hasn't talked to when a long time to let
him know that she made a class it's
pretty obvious at this point that Taichi
is crushing on her so this kind of sucks
for him to have to watch her always
thinking about audit at first when she
calls him to tell him the good news he
says that he doesn't play cod ot anymore
and to not call him back
episode bye Chihaya is worried about
audit ah after talking um so she drags
Taichi along to go see him well heading
there tight she almost makes his move
which accused the blocking of genitalia
by auditor who rides by on his bike
instead of yelling out like a normal
person she higher rips him off his bike
and he lands on top of her getting me
all hot and bothered ji Hye's suggests
the three of them play a game of cat a
tough but this irritates audit and he's
really cool to them forcing them to
leave we learned that audits his
grandfather Hajime what Thea held the
title of Mahim and was known as eternal
master Hajime Hajime time out of 10
everything he knows about kata and they
were very close so after he passed away
audit I gave up on playing in the last
scene audited chases after their train
on his bike suggesting that he wanted to
see them and doesn't hate kata time
Taichi then goes on to agree on making a
cut at a club with Chihaya episode 6
we're getting introduced to kannada Oh a
who is in love with Japanese traditions
like the poems in kata so she takes an
interest in the club most of the episode
is Chihaya trying to convince her to
join she goes to coa at her parents
traditional clothing shop where they get
to talking about the poems Chihaya is
fascinated by the meanings behind all of
the poems and the discussion helps her
get even better after talking always
finally convinced into joining the club
episode 7 through club needs 5 members
for it to be an official Club so cahaya
goes out to scout for their fourth
member
this queues the introduction of the
bookworm suit Tomoko Mennella
sure I had takes a more hands-on
approach while making him join since he
does
one two because he's obsessed with his
grades look if a hot girl asks you to
join a club you just do it I don't
really like the club who cares she could
be thirsty she could be asking because
she's thirsty for you and if not you
know then she can be stuck in there but
it's totally worth the risk
but anyways GI explains that cata tel
will help him with memorizing at
schoolwork but he doesn't buy it he
challenges them to play with the cards
down to prove that they can actually
memorize where they're at this actually
gives Tai Chi an edge and for the first
time he wins against ji-hye feeding his
competitive drive Camano explains that
he doesn't have the natural talent to
play cada toe after hearing this tied
she has a short talk with him and is
able to convince him to join the team
yepez O'Day could continue recruiting
for their last member and she higher
recognizes you say mishneh who was one
of the kids that played cata to when
they were little he ended up quitting
because he was ranked second in Japan
during elementary school and always got
smashed by a data who was ranked 1 he
decided he was never gonna be able to
beat him so he gave up on trying Mischa
agrees to play a game against Chihaya
but if he wins she has to agree to stop
pestering him about joining he turns out
to still be really good and gives her a
run for her money well playing he
remembers how much he loved contest so
after the match he quits the Tennis Club
to become their fifth member
episode 9 we get a little more
information on the rankings with new
players starting at Class E and then
climbing their way up to class a Lisa
and Tai Chi are both Class B and they
have to win or get runner-up in two
competitions to move up to Class A all
of them decide to do a training camp so
they head to Tai Chi's house since his
parents are away Chi hai makes a
rigorous practice schedule but it ends
up getting cut short when Tai Chi's mom
comes home without notice forcing the
girls to sneak out later that night Oh a
pulls Chihaya out where they meet the
guys in celebrate ji hyo's birthday once
again Tai Chi gets his manhood blocked
by a text from Auditor wishing her a
happy birthday and apologizing II
episode 10 the time has come for them to
put their skills to the test and the
qualifiers for the high school nationals
at the competition she higher runs into
hito again who's representing Haku
Academy they entered a team competition
where the format is 5 e 5 and there has
to be three winners on their school's
team to advance to the next round
they win the first round against Aiko
Academy three-two
they're newer members coming out and Oh
way losing in the second round they go
against [ __ ] again we're away wins her
first match advancing them further
kimono kinda puts a damper on things
when he wants to quit because he hasn't
won a match yet the semis are against
Tommy hot a Wes where they are forced to
play for v 5 because commando is being a
baby and sitting this one out
chihaya's off her game and they merely
lose but she claws back from a massive
deficit to win the match in the last
scene kimono apologizes and says he
wants to play in the finals
episode 11 who are the finals they go up
against Hoku Academy with Chihaya
gaining and losing momentum against her
opponent a pseudo who's known for being
a crazy sadist Mishnah is also
struggling while thinking about how much
better he could have been if he didn't
quit
Bufo way and comeno lose their matches
leaving it up to the others to carry
tonight she gets them on the board with
his win and meesh to follow suit soon
after you know it's all up to Chihaya
and luckily her Chihaya voodoo card is
the last one called leaving the
opposition no chance as she never misses
that card in the last scene Auto Tech
gets a message saying that they
qualified and for him to go to ohmy
shrine to watch them compete at
nationals
yep assaut 12 chihaya's excited about
winning the qualifiers but she is
constantly overshadowed by her older
sister cheeto say who's trying to make
it in show business
her parents always seem so distracted
with her sisters so she can't find the
right time to tell them her good news to
help prepare for the upcoming tournament
Chihaya and Taichi go to practice with
Haneda at his society later Chihaya
finds out that her parents are actually
following her success and making a
scrapbook out of her cotta
accomplishments Tilikum youichi one of
their teachers never really gave much
mind to their club and was always
focused on the Tennis Club until she saw
them practicing one day she sees how
much work they put into kata and takes a
new interest in them offering to
accompany them to the ohmy shrine
episode 13 they arrive at the shrine to
compete in the high school nationals ah
data is on his way there as well and we
get more details on when he stopped
playing he was always looking after his
grandfather who had early signs of
dementia and started forgetting him and
Kurata altogether he fights through
these memories and goes inside bright as
Chihaya passes out in the first round
for
her to forfeit her match she wakes up to
find auditive there but is taken to the
hospital before they could really talk
later on she runs into sudo from the
qualifiers who's pissed because she
knocked them out and then went on to
forfeit at Nationals even though it
really wasn't her fault
we learned that coming a won his first
game but they ended up losing against
Fujisaki Academy on Atta had also left
her gift saying that the next time they
meet will be in a match meaning that
he's gonna start playing Cod attest
seriously again episode 14 even though
the team tournament is over they still
have the individual tournament to
compete in we get the official
introduction to Shinobu waka Mia the
Queen which is the title of the best
female cut it to player in Japan this is
the title that every cut of two player
is shooting for including she hiya so
this is a girl she's gonna have to be to
earn that title the individual
tournament gets underway and Shinobu
goes on to defeat now Yuta I'm a costume
from Haku Academy with a 24 card
difference GI o wins her match also and
ends up getting placed against Shinobu
in the next round it becomes painfully
obvious that the queen is on a whole
nother level
jo is reminded of being severely
outclassed by auditive when they first
played but rallies just enough to take a
couple of cards off of her yep so 15 by
the end of the match Chihaya had only
taken five cards losing by 20 Shinobu
ends up facing against sudo in the
finals and wins by 12 cards away and
kuma net were both competing in the
lower divisions and knocked out in the
third round
Taichi on the other hand made it all the
way to the Class B finals so everybody
goes to cheer for him he ends up losing
but it was a really close match with him
only being down three cards at the end
of it losers all head back and use their
summer break to continue improving we
also get a look at out of time making
his return by joining the Fukunaga mo
kata to society episode 16 is a recap
episode so don't worry about that one
episode 17 we get some filler content
with the Sports Festival being held at
their school and the kata tickle of
competing in it they all get together to
discuss the upcoming competitions and
decide which ones they're going to enter
to improve their ranks
Taichi is shooting for Class A which is
the minimum to enter the machine Queen
Eastern Japan qualifiers the most
important competition of the year this
is where people go at it for the right
to compete for the title of queen
by becoming the eastern japan delegate
to improve his rank Taichi goes to a
Class B tournament where he ends up
running in Tunisia who was also
competing they both end up losing not
making any progress towards our promos
episode 18
Chihaya has her first class a match
outside of high school competition
against Suk CUDA cannot the others are
also at the same tournament trying to
rank up
she loses by 6 cards but learns a lot
from her opponent about not playing so
fast while refining her accuracy and
timing jump over to the others we're
tight she and mishneh both made it to
the Class B finals and had to square off
against each other but it's not just
them comon oh and oh we made it to the
Class D finals so they have to play
against each other also
episode 19 with both finals happening at
the same time ji-hye has more focused on
the Class D final cumino starts choking
pretty hard and making a lot of mistakes
he almost rallies to make a comeback but
the deficit is too great and oay ends up
winning the finals the Class B finals
are as close as it gets with both Taichi
and me stood down to one card each and
entering sudden-death do last card bread
is on Miche decide giving him an
overwhelming advantage since he's so
much closer
he of course wins making Taichi the
runner-up the rules are different for
Class D with the top three at a
tournament getting promoted to Class C
so come on oh and Oh a move up a class
mishneh had also moved up to Class A
after his victory leaving Taichi behind
in Class B jump over to a DITA who's
also going to be competing in the
machine Queen tournament to become the
Western delegate episode 20 ji-hye has
been too focused on kata tests so her
grades are suffering she is forced to
skip a tournament to get her grades
boosted by kuma no the tournament is
just for a and V class members so Taichi
decides he'll go by himself because
mishneh is studying also normally you
can rank up from two second-place
finishes which Taichi has gotten but the
society that him and she hiya are a part
of require that he wins first place
before he can rank up he wants to
compete in the machine queen tournament
and this is his last chance to get Class
A before then well there he happens to
run into a Teta who's competing as well
in Class A chihaya's sneaks out of her
studies because she wants to go support
Taichi when she arrives she learns that
he lost in the third round but also that
is competing cahaya is mesmerized by how
he plays but he ends up losing to some
bad luck towards the end of his match
everybody parts White's after a short
talk that was pretty much irrelevant and
later even though it's not part of the
Shiva Nami society rules how did that
offers to advance Tai Chi to Class A
this way he'll be able to participate in
the masion qualifiers along with Chihaya
he appreciates the offer but he
ultimately turns it down because he
wants to earn it properly e episode 21
Mel we're gonna jump ahead to the start
of the Easter Japan qualifiers this is
the big one and in the first round Nita
is going up against sudo chihaya's
against the Itachi Kawa who is said to
be the next Shinobu and is only in 6th
grade
the little girl reminds Chihaya of how
she used to be when she only focused on
speed chihaya's experience gives her the
advantage and she goes on to smash the
little prodigy making it through the
first round
yep Izzo 22 and her second match
chihaya's placed against Yamamoto yume
who was the former queen that was
dethroned by Shinobu we also learned
that nishta got killed by sudo in their
match losing by 20 cards so he's kind of
down in the dumps but anyways back to
the match Yumi is discouraged after
suffering so many defeats and only
retaining the Queen title for one year
giving off this vibe like she has given
up this makes Chihaya even more
determined because she doesn't want to
lose a single card against somebody who
isn't even trying you Rumi picks up on
this and out of nowhere gains a second
win fighting for cards and arguing
constantly about who is faster in the
end she is able to pull the match back
into her favor and winds knocking
Chihaya out of the qualifiers episode 23
know that ji-hye and East are out of the
running they go to cheer for their
instructor Haneda who's competing
against sudo but of it ends up winning
the match by three cars but you can tell
since he's older he's starting to run
out of energy he loses in the
semi-finals so the eastern Japan
Reformation is Hilo she's super Gucci
which is the a Senshi high society and
also the one who be audited when she
hiya watched them play the rep for Quinn
ended up being Yumi keeping her dreams
of reclaiming her title alive and one
month the two of them will go against
the reps from Western Japan and the
winner of that will have earned the
chance to challenge the Kurd machine or
Queen Edyta who is participating in the
Western qualifiers made it pretty far
but ended up
losing in the fourth round Tilikum
buddha had won the Western qualifiers
and beat Super Gucci in their match
giving him the opportunity to challenge
the current machine Yumi wins her match
against the Western delegate earning a
rematch against Shinobu episode 24
Chihaya goes over to Tai Chi's house to
watch the Machine and green matches with
him in the others
Shinobu had put on a couple of pounds so
she's looking extra thick for her match
her recent weight gain is working
against her and she appears to be much
slower than before this doesn't stop her
though and she goes on to win the final
match in the series by 13 cards
retaining her title yeah we get our
first look at the current machine he saw
she's sOooo during his match against
taka muta they missed her earlier
matches were sOooo won by five cards on
the first match and 13 on the second
match doc amudha feels helpless in the
matches being severely outclassed by soo
who has retained the machine title for
three years straight episode 25 soooo
goes on to win the match no problem with
all of the characters studying his
techniques he says that he can
distinguish multiple syllable cards
apart from one another on the first
syllable which is similar to what she
hiya is able to do after hearing this
she tries harder to get multiple
syllable cards on their first syllable
later on Oh a talk Swift Chihaya and
expresses that she has a newfound dream
to become a qualified reader and read at
she highs queen match however to become
a reader you also have to get into Class
A which is a tad bit discouraging for
her but she is determined and practices
reading further Club matches speaking of
the club their classroom is being
contested by another teacher so in order
to retain such a large room they have to
get 5 new members I'm going to be doing
the future seasons and that'll be in the
bottom up front of I'm finished with it
or you can check out all the cahaya Fudo
recaps in this playlist here you can
also find the links in the description
below and the only thing I hate more
than intros is outros